We'd started the Cartoon Network or were in the process of doing it...
...and I said, you know, there ought to be a cartoon series that has some meat on the bones.
And I said, "We need a superhero for the Earth,"...
...and I came up with kind of a Superman type, Superman, Batman type character...
...who was green and really we decided that...
...but at that point I got a woman named Barbara Pyle who worked with me in the environmental area.
And I got her involved, and she and a fellow named Nick Boxer really produced the show, they took it to the next steps...
...but I came up with the idea of Captain Planet: we had to have a name for him.
And Superman wouldn't do it, that was already taken so...
...Captain Planet was a good name.
There's a lesson and message as well as great entertainment in every episode.
I was an environmentalist when I was a little kid; the natural world fascinated me.
I was reading books before I could read, looking at the pictures of animals and birds and flowers.